Megan Mullally you guys been married how
long now seventeen we've been together
17 years married 14 that's great and you
know I didn't know I never knew that
when you guys first met she assumed
because I've known you a long time and
you've always looked this way I think
you looked this way when you were a
nine-year-old boy I think you had a
beard and you were smoking the cigar in
the corner with a mule did did she was
shocked at how young you were is that
right yeah she had been kind of dating
young younger skinnier like rock drummer
types she's she thought she wasn't
looking to settle down and then we met
doing a play and she said oh hey maybe
this may be my fling time is over and
this guy seems substantial and he does
the dishes yeah and so we began to
canoodle as can I say that on this is a
good honest show things things began to
spark between us and and we were in her
car going to dinner on an early date and
and it came out she thought because I
speak slowly that I was mature but it
came out that I was about 11 years
younger than her and I remember very
clearly what she said she said you
mother
I said I like that you asked me about
canoodle you know but then went ahead
with that you know well that was a quote
yeah just being accurate you guys did a
photo shoot recently were you dressed as
Sonny and Cher but you flipped it around
I love this the way you went for it yeah
fantastic
it's called brave comedy that's brave
comedy was it how did you feel seeing
your first of all that's quite a daring
outfit you went for did you know that
you would be revealing that much in a
cher outfit no you know you know you get
into these things where they pitch a
funny idea and they say what if you guys
are Sonny and Cher but we flip it you're
like oh that's funny
yeah and I think Oh probably being some
sort of full-length buckskin outfit
right that's Cher's go to get up I
didn't expect a small rectangle of latex
or you got lucky cuz she doesn't she has
she's famous for the assless chaps too
so well you could have been wearing
those we got lucky
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you